we went in and ironically enough the
table next to ours was 50 cent
um and in the back there was kanye west
uh beyonce
i had 50 cent pass me a bottle of vodka
and stuff yeah it was crazy
absolutely mental
well matt plays me again
okay first question how much money did
you win
on the lottery i won 6.1 million
jesus i'm a trained engineer but i was
made redundant
when i was uh working as a bus driver
in north staff south cheshire i remember
this story
on the news that's right yes how about
you
just a meal for me my head space at that
point
was was really difficult i mean i was in
a flat i couldn't afford by myself
uh on a single wage uh i was in a job
that i'd started
three weeks before that that i
absolutely hated and was
contemplating leaving living for every
weekend going out every weekend
i had about 20 grand worth of visa debt
my i was going to move back in with my
dad
tell us about the night when you won i
was meant to have
dinner with my brother and some friends
my brother and our other mate decided to
bin it and go
on a date so it left me with my one
friend
he basically wanted to go get some food
so we went to morrisons across the road
and i was bored to the back teeth of him
picking different
stakes up deciding what stake he wanted
so i thought well
i'm going to wait outside before i slap
him around the head with a steak
and at that point i walked past the
kiosk bought my lucky dip
dip ticket and then we left watch
chelsea napoli
great game for all um four in the
morning i was getting ready for a night
shift the following day
trying not to fall asleep and i thought
what can i do
i'll check my lottery ticket so um was
checking it on my phone pitch black
um didn't win scrunched it up put it to
the sides
um still on my phone it started flashing
for some reason saying
remember to check your raffle tickets so
i've
obviously unscrambled the ticket looked
there was a raffle thing at the bottom
put the number in and said
congratulations you won a million pounds
so that was it
i always think it would never happen to
me and now it has happened to me
i think i'd never do it again but then
again i know people
that have won twice so maybe i should
what about yourself so did you literally
was that the first time you played well
yeah yeah yeah goodness man
on a lucky day yeah i've been playing
for well since
since it first started obviously you
probably had the same you don't believe
ever that this thing's happened to you
so
i tried ringing my brother my mum my
dad's no one pick up because it was so
early in the morning
but because my friends were out in bali
i facetimed them they were all around
the pool
sun shining so there was me in a pitch
black flat
with my ticket one side my face the
other they were checking the numbers for
me
obviously realized i won um all started
diving in the pool
started ordering champagne they started
upgrading their hotel rooms so by the
time i got to bali
i had this bill to pay that i hadn't
even contributed towards
about yourself i can always remember
looking at the first two numbers
thinking yes we've got that one i've got
that one
and i thought oh we're in for a few quid
here this number
wow this is a couple of grand and then
the six number tallied
so i went running out in the study into
the living room
i ran in saying i've won the lottery
week won the lottery
and my wife turned around to me and she
said what do you want 10 pounds
and i said no i've won the lot and she
said what do you mean you've won the lot
i said i've won the jackpot i asked my
wife
to ring up on my behalf at 9am when the
camelot office opened
in the meantime i went off to work a lot
of people on that route depended on that
bus to get to work in the morning
so that's really selfless i would have
not done that
describe the moment when you thought i'm
rich
where we lived before i won they built a
brand new
jaguar showroom and uh
crew's quite a working-class town yeah
and i always used to think
who on earth can afford to buy jugs from
a garage like that yeah and then the
next thing you know it's me that's going
in there as a customer
brilliant you know ultimately bought an
xj so no way it's amazing
i guess my i'm rich moment was
on valentine's in 2015
um i went out to see a friend in america
and he was like look let's go to this
nba all-star weekend
um party in new york i think that table
on that
was about 5 000 we went in and
ironically enough the table next to ours
was 50 cent
he's a rapper and in the back there was
kanye west beyonce there was load of the
new england patriots football team
i had 50 cent pass me a bottle of vodka
and stuff yeah it was crazy
absolutely mental
have your taste become more expensive
i still shop at aldi yes same it's
amazing
yes i now drive a big a much bigger car
i've got a bigger house
i make sure that from october to
february i go away for one week right of
every month of the winter
to make it a very short winter yeah and
that stops me getting bored where have
you just come back from
uh well we've just been on a trip
uh on the great rail journeys
uh through switzerland on the uh
on the snow train yeah beautiful i
always wanted to do that
what about you um so yeah you know going
into nightclubs
getting tables buying clothes
um that you wouldn't be able to afford i
mean i bought a tuxedo
the the jacket was two and a half grand
that was in savile row
it was a pretty woman moment for me
actually i went in tracksuit
went into one shop and they kind of
ushered me out he shouldn't be in here
went across the road bought this really
expensive tuxedo
you know walked out of it on my back and
waving at the guys who fought past
so yeah my my tastes now have subsided a
little bit but i do love the
the better things in life if you like
purely because i probably didn't have
them growing up
it's a life i wanted to experience two
years
i didn't work um and i was going from
place to place you know seeing all all
parts of the world and
i didn't really concentrate on my bank
balance stupidly so
once you start checking it and then you
realize
actually this isn't going to last
forever my mum
basically dished out this royal
bollocking
and said you know you need to stop
spending money like it's water
because no one wants to be the sob story
if you like
so i've made every effort to not become
that person and i feel
like it's working out so far and now i'm
probably
well i know i'm worth more than what i
actually won so
how did winning the lottery impact on
your relationships
my friends all became very close it was
almost
as though if you weren't a friend before
you couldn't be a friend after
so i don't know how it felt for you but
it instantly felt like a weighted lifted
um i became more confident as i put not
that i lack confidence
at all but i found myself feeling like
invincible paying off all my family's
debts
which is an incredible feeling you know
because i was in a better mental state i
started speaking to my parents now so i
started to treat my friends nicer
um and things like that so yeah i guess
it made me
i consider myself a better person what
about you it gives me time to be
with my family i can look after my
grandson now
and help out the rest of the family yeah
so the one key
thing that it's given me is time and
that's so precious to me
there's one thing i do miss and that is
the uh camaraderie
of uh work colleagues of course
i i do miss that you know i just met i
do miss the
the chat because you don't see as many
people as you used to see obviously you
become
slightly isolated i think in some ways
yeah i agree
overall i'd say that i have less friends
now
but uh different types of friends yeah
of course i don't know if you're on
social media or anything like that but
um because of social media i mean i was
getting
inboxes letters daily pretty much for
the first 18 months maybe
i didn't want to say no but you kind of
have to be
good about it you can't just say you
know bugger off
who do you think you're talking to et
cetera so unfortunately i can't help if
i helped everyone that asked
i actually wouldn't have any money left
because it did really get that bad
luckily it's died down now five years
later but i'd say i'd still probably get
at least one a month
i found it contrary to that i i found
that when i was going around crew
people that saw me recognize me even
even people i didn't know
were like shooting car horns and putting
their thumbs up yeah and things like
that you know which quite surprised me
because
a lot of people i did know were saying
oh you'll be getting begging letters
here you'll be getting
please for this please for that and it
never happened
do you think winning the lotteries
changed you what it did was
almost amplify my personality so i mean
i was a generous i liked to think i was
a generous guy before
so if anything it made me more generous
and
i've always been a confident lad it made
me more confident i've probably always
been the loudest in the room and now
i sound like a foghorn so if anything
like i said it's it's made me bigger and
better but i wouldn't say it's changed
me
what about you quite a few people i've
met that i used to
work with and uh that i knew socially
that's the first thing they say it
hasn't changed yet and my immediate
response is
well why should it because at the end of
the day
it's it's money yeah of course at that
point in time
it really changed my life and since then
i've i mean i've met the person that i'm
going to be with for the rest of my life
i've got
two beautiful children and i own my own
house
i never thought that was going to be
achievable you know when you look at the
bank balance and it's
minus 20 grand and you don't have your
own car
and you don't have your own house and
stuff it's really difficult
if i could jump out of bed with both
hands in the air every day i would but
you start to feel a bit of a knob
the main thing that the money has been
able to do
is give me time to enjoy the things that
i enjoyed
doing before that i wasn't always able
to do i mean if i could bottle
happiness and sell it i'd be a
multi-millionaire now i mean
i haven't had a sad day since um
get never look at price tag get to go
where i want when i want
you know being able to bring your boss
and quit work was
one of the best conversations i've ever
had on the phone
um so yeah i'm beyond happy i guess
pleasure to me it's been nice meeting
you great chat yeah
same here and uh long may your happiness
continue thank you
thank you the most dangerous thing
i have ever done is going into combat
but the most safest thing i've ever done
is strange but you're in control you
know you've got
your weapon you've got the boys behind
you you're the aggressor
it's a different type of um control